la ville de Limone porte les stigmates
de la guerre
rassemblés sur cette place pour recevoir
des médicaments et du pain ces habitants
gardent un souvenir amer de 5 mois
d'occupation russe
nous ont traités moi j'ai été arrêté et
détenu pendant deux jours juste parce
qu'il n'aimait pas la façon dont je l'ai
regardé
ces jeunes n'ont pas peur de parler
d'autres restent méfiants comme Valera
certains s'attendent un retour des
Russes
nous pouvons être sûr de rien maintenant
nous vivons au jour le jour avec ce que
Dieu nous donne c'est tout
les Russes sont essuyés ici une défaite
cuisante et ont dû battre en retraite
sans même avoir eu le temps de ramasser
leur butin comme la ferme la police
ukrainienne
ils ont trouvé beaucoup de nouvelles
choses et avait prévu des emporter
cette retraite précipité a coupé court à
l'organisation du référendum pour
rejoindre la Russie
vous avez écrit les noms
étaient en faveur de la chanson
à la sortie de la ville un cimetière
d'équipements militaire russe
le porte-parole de l'armée ukrainienne a
un message pour les habitants qui
craignaient leur retour il y a quelques
jours
mais toute son énergie pour s'assurer
que les Russes auront tellement peur
qu'ils n'oseront même pas penser à
revenir pour le moment c'est clairement
l'armée ukrainienne qui a l'initiative
la reprise de l'imam lui a permis
d'avancer vers le nord-est et même de
pénétrer la région de luansk qui était
la seule des quatre régions que Vladimir
Poutine voulait annexer à avoir été
entièrement contrôlé par la Russie
voilà on décrypte